the end of human nature isn't it there's
a there's an important book from the
last century by the Harvard biologist
eio Wilson it's called on human nature
and he talks about human nature has
certain parameters now there's there's a
variation within those parameters but he
says try to imagine a human being that
decided I'm going to be a toad right he
goes but I mean not just I identify like
a toad like I want to look like a toad I
wear a toad costume or something but I
want to be a toad I a toad in fact I'm a
toad in a human body I'm really a toad
but I'm in the wrong body he goes you
would have to go down to the creek and
jump around in the water and eat what
toads eat and be a toad right now
imagine if someone actually did that now
I think most of us at least the
libertarian streaking us would be that's
interesting let's go check that dude out
you know and but it would be a whole
different matter if that guy then began
to demand that that the whole of society
recognize him as a toad right and and so
this effort to not only say my mind has
given me this new identity but I'm now
insisting that
you subscribe to this ident you buy into
my illusion so to speak yes this is
where I think we go off the rail but
where are we going if we do go into this
metaverse we had that Lex fredman Mark
Zuckerberg interview did you guys see it
I think you pointed out of it where
their their anim CGI figures it looks
just like them and they're talking from
across the country but they're in the
same room sitting down and you can see
their bodies and face moving as if
they're not you know it's it's real-time
generation here's what's going to happen
you you think it's absurd to recognize
the toad person when the whole world is
in the metaverse there is going you're
going to walk into your business you're
going to put on your headset and you're
going to grab your controllers heptic
feedback or whatever your avatar will be
you regular old dases walking you'll sit
down at this table and be like all right
everybody ready for for the production
meeting and there will be a giant toad
and there will be a giant carrot person
and then there will be a Godzilla and
that's how they identify and so the Frog
man will be like I would like to discuss
and you're like that's just that's what
we do now the in the in the reality in
which we operate people are whatever
they want to be I've been continuing to
remind people that if you're a human man
and you identify whatever is a woman is
a brick wall you're both a woman and a
human man you never stop becoming one
you're still a human man that identifies
you don't become anything else well you
identify as something else but you never
truly stop being a human man that's part
of your experience a human man who
identifies as a carrot is still a human
man who identifies as a carrot yeah
exactly and you can be both there's an
imprecision here because the person
who's saying that wants you to believe
even though they use the sly word
identify what they really mean is I am a
woman in the wrong body they're not
saying I am imagining myself to be a
woman I'm a man who imagines myself to
be a woman what they're saying is I
really am a woman but I am in a sense in
I've I've been ascribed the wrong
biology and that's why I have to
undertake all these surgeries and
hormones and all this stuff this matters
now but when we are in a digital reality
there will be no question because you'll
meet some you you you'll be talking to
as far as you can tell in virtual
reality a woman and you'll have no idea
that it's a middle-aged morbidly obese
man behind the screen it's in the movie
surrogates uh with Bruce Willis this is
the first thing they introduce it's like
there's some hot woman and some dude at
a club making out the movie is about
people who use robots to Pilot the world
for them because it's safer and then
when they go when this when the when the
person dies the the the surrogate of the
female dies they're like let's go track
down the owner and see what happened
they walk into this very beautiful
apartment and there's a 500b man in the
machine who's dead and they're like
that's her yep that's great yep
you get that a little bit in in uh role
playing games like World of Warcraft and
stuff where a dude chooses to play as a
as a female half elf or a female night
elf and I'm like Well's but I don't I
don't see that I don't see that as as
the same way it's a question of when you
when when you play with dolls are you
controlling the doll or are you becoming
the doll and everybody kind of does it
differently right I do yeah I don't I
don't become I mean I I guess you could
you could pretend to be you're making
the characters you're like hello I'm
this guy yeah I'm this guy if you if
you're if you're playing in World of
Warcraft and you're role playing and
you're like I would like to be a a half
fale whatever people would get what's
that you acknowledge it's a game and not
reality cuz you're playing a a game
right people get married in the game and
do you identify as your character or is
your character a thing you manipulate
yeah but it was you're right because it
was some people were that was just a
manipulative character some people they
started to identify I think and then
maybe it's psychoactives maybe it's like
Pharma drugs that are making people at
12 years old not know reality from
fiction no I I mean it depends some
people go into these games specifically
to roleplay as a character that either
is or is not thems but when I played
World of Warcraft I had like seven
different we call them tunes and some
were male and some were female it was
just like action figures yeah but and
then if someone asks you like are you a
girl and you're like yes that's when it
goes a little crazy we were on what was
it team speak and what was the other one
was it vector or whatever um there's a
lot of them was it I think it's like
vector chat yeah everybody knows who we
are we're hanging out together and it's
like we're I I I it's like playing with
action figures it's almost as if what's
happening in our society is that at one
level we're seeing
increased clampdown regimentation
control uh governments Elites and and
it's not just governments I mean our
police state is a little bit unique in
that it sprawls across the private
sector too I mean think of censorship
censorship involves Academia it involves
the media it involves nonprofit
institutions it involves the government
and the digital platforms so an acad mic
will make up a list right and let's just
say Tim pool and I on the list got to
ban these two guys that list will then
be picked up by the Biden Administration
which will then sort it oh Timol is
spreading lies about the election send
it over to cisa the cyber security and
infrastructure Aid dases is spreading
lies about coid send them over to the
CDC so all these agencies compile these
lists but then they don't want to
explicitly censor because they might get
caught so they hand it off to a
middleman they go to the Stanford
internet Observatory the virality
project they go guys you take this list
and you deliver it to the digital
platforms so that way we're out of it
you and so that they do the handoff the
digital platforms ban you and the media
cheers and they don't make any specific
statements of fact that way they can't
be sued so I actually deal with this
they I think Stanford claimed that I was
one of the largest uh uh me and a few
other people were the biggest promoters
of of disinformation in the in the
during the 2020 election which is the
weirdest thing to say I did because I
have like the most tepid opinions on
these things and we use newsguard which
is Microsoft funded not like they have
they have a contract deal so they're
getting a lot of financing through a
deal with
Microsoft I put out a story where I'm
like hey look local Fox Outlet says X
and they're like Tim pool spreads
disinformation you ask them where or how
they don't have to tell you and they
don't have to argue what is or isn't and
you can't swim over it I mean to me the
most creepy word that came out of the
Twitter files was Mal information so Mal
information is information that's true
yeah but harmful to the ideology of the
regime kind of something like you can
take the vaccine and you can still get
Co and you can still give Co well people
go wait a minute that how is it a quote
vaccine vaccines by definition prevent
you from getting it you and so that
becomes Malin it's not wrong it's
actually true that's why they want to
ban you at first it was I think it was
misinformation and they were like some
people are spreading information
accidentally incorrect then it became
disinformation I like now they're
intentionally doing it then Mal
information it may be true but it is bad
for a lot of reasons that I mean again
flashing back you know a generation
disinformation used to mean information
that is deliberately false that is put
out by a government Soviet
disinformation coming out through Pravda
is vestia all these Soviet propag but
the idea that an ordinary individual
debating a vaccine could be doing
disinformation is absurd you can be
misinformed you could be even malicious
you could be lying but disinformation
again that term was ripped out of its
original context and used in a
completely different context I mean I I
would assume um that a that a citizen
could provide disinformation as if they
were a Soviet government like one one
brilliant guy that has access to a lot
of data could could definitely with a
lot of followers could seed like a false
narrative but the argument was that in a
free Marketplace of ideas your peers
could check you they could challenge you
so the idea that you could monopolize
information it wouldn't really work
whereas on the other hand if a
government was doing it then they could
sort of control the flow of it here's
the challenge let's say the government
releases an AI image and then the people
check that image and says hey wait a
minute this is AI generated then news
organizations through statements made by
the government confirm actually it's
real and people what do you do you've
got multiple news organizations and a
government saying actually we checked
it's real and users being like we ran
algorithms and said it's fake people are
going to be it's it's just nonsense
world there's nothing that's true
anymore that's where that's where we're
entering we're in this we're we're here
now to some degree think about how often
we are told who do you believe us or
Your Lying Eyes you know so take January
6th most of us had a pretty good view of
what happened there was a lot of
coverage of the event you could see yeah
there was some episodic violence there
were some clashes some of it got pretty
bad there were people who climbed
through windows and up up the banisters
and so on at other stages you have
people wandering very carefully through
the ropes making sure not to deface or
damage anything and so all of this was
right there in front of you to see but
then a whole manufactured narrative came
up which was quite different from what
we saw and the January 6 committee is
believe this don't believe what you saw
yep I think of that with 911 too when I
watch those buildings fall in near Free
Fall speed just like well you take a
look at January 6 being a good example
we did on this show I think this was
almost two years ago now I talked about
how on January 6 we would likely end up
with with January 6 likely end up seeing
acquittal because you can't charge
someone with trespass unless they've
been warned they're trespassing and so
the problem with January 6 is that many
people arrived later on in the day when
the fences were removed the doors were
opened by the police and they walked in
confused The Young Turks particularly
Jen yuger made a made a clip insulting
me saying that's the stupidest argument
ever Tim pool's a as if these
people are fighting with police and
walking over broken glass and don't know
they're trespassing you see the problem
was that jenin Anna did not actually
know what happened on January 6th they
had only seen what CNN wanted them to
see and they didn't know on the other
side of the building cops opened the
door and fanned people in well sure
enough a couple months later there was a
hard acqu one man argued to the judge
the police fanned me in the defense
plays a video of the cops going like
this and waving them in and the judge
said you are correct sir you are free to
go case dismissed and that's not the
only one another man got acquitted on uh
uh on the trespass charge because the
police no he got he got acquitted on a
bunch of charges in including the
trespass without warning but then he got
a lighter charge because he climbed over
a barricade later on or something to
that effect there was like a half aittle
some of the charges got dropped because
the police are seen Fanning him in but
then later on he climbed past a
barricade or something but we've seen
several people get acquitted because the
cops fann him in if The Young Turks
don't know this then of course they're
going to say how could Tim say something
like this the problem is an inquisitive
mind would say wait wait wait what is
Timo talking about right people didn't
know how is that possible let let me
search for this whoa I didn't realize
the cops fanned people in this is one of
the biggest challenges we face right now
in the culture war is ignorant anger but
it's even more than that now it's
ignorant like I haven't seen all the
videos coming out of Gaza or Israel I
haven't so I'm ignorant I don't know
what's going on but then I see videos
that aren't real so I start to think
that I have seen what's going on but it
what didn't actually happen thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net